all right cool
are we are we good to shoot know Dimitri
or not why is there a mountain of bread
in your shot
what isn't everyone learning new skills
during shelter-in-place I mean I've been
on a baking spree but honestly I'm
getting pretty sick of just eating bread
what do you mean you're just eating
bread you're not like making sandwiches
or something well I was but then I ran
out of things to put on it and I don't
really want to go to the grocery store
dude why don't you just order the food
with GrubHub you can still get all the
food you want without actually leaving
your house they do that that's what I'm
saying dude plus all your food will be
delivered safely through their contact
free delivery service that sounds
convenient that's because it is and
GrubHub lets you support your favorite
restaurants with a daily perk that gives
you $10 off orders over $30 between 5
p.m. and 9 p.m. at select restaurants so
you could stop eating bread and eat
almost anything else yeah that's great
but what am I supposed to do with all
this Brent chances are if you've managed
to crack the upper echelon of your
eSports you're known for something maybe
it was a calculated act a truly
masterful outplay
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe it was something crazy the result
of sheer unadulterated madness and it
looks like for the Marvin rolling ball
to offer
[Applause]
or maybe it was just something really
really stupid
it doesn't matter if it's a moment
maneuver or missplay it's immutable
something that will never ever forget
the thing for which you as a competitor
are forever immortalized is coming and
in some cases an inescapable hell but
what if I told you that one of the
greatest most lively and most adored
smashers of all time was a little
different that there was one name in
particular one of the most infamous in
all of eSports that means well literally
anything meet Joseph mango marques
whether he's pulling off a disgusting
edge guard or falling through the floor
of a house one thing can be said with
absolute certainty about anything that
he does that's the mango
he got mango definitely got mango a
proto up error that's it be it he hits
mango with the mango so how is it that
the mango came to mean basically
anything that this Smasher and his
community of fans wanted it to and when
you get down to it does it actually make
a ton of sense
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now for those of you who are into we're
super smash brothers melee has long been
ruled by five gods kind of like how in
the godfather New York City is run by
the five families the difference being
that these guys aren't interested in
money and power
no they're obsessed with mastering a
nearly 20 year old party game
needless to say mango is one of those
sweaty ass gods
he's also hands down the wildest part of
that has to do with his personality
let's just say that mango is a bit of a
party animal
[Music]
but a lot of it has to do with the way
that he approaches smash you see for a
long time
mango was pretty much regarded as the
most talented melee player in the world
he annihilated everyone in sight made
insane loser bracket runs and won evo
twice in a row mr. - Todd - Todd the
hats in the crowd there's a Mexican flag
but he's from the States I don't know
what's going on but mango has done it
the reason for mangoes sustained
dominance was fairly simple the guy was
a natural you'll see him he'll do the
craziest combo that was what do you make
sense you wouldn't think it would work
and he just knows it work it's not
something that can really be explained
or learned I don't think it's just
something that kind of happens the
entire room is fighting mango now hold
me we got that yeah but unlike a lot of
fighting game divinities mango isn't
renowned for his game knowledge he
famously hates frame data and to say
that he couldn't care less about
traditional fgc terminology would be an
understatement but no it's sick because
it dodges an attack with now go down
here no see that's the thing
mango doesn't play with his head he
doesn't even really play with his heart
he plays with his balls he just doesn't
have a flowchart he literally is such an
instinctual player you just
he feels out the game sometimes that is
going mango playing against mango it's
more like if the train is coming at you
and you're not ready then you're dead
you got a dodge to train and if you can
dodge the train it slow yeah that's one
can go in he's a guy that likes to push
limits and get into people's heads so
it's not really like a this is my game
plan this is how the matchup works it's
what is my opponent making and how do I
get into his head and what are the
little things I can do to say that I
clearly outplayed and outsmarted him
mango plays with pure intuition what's
more he isn't repetitive doesn't rely on
a set strategy and there's ostensibly no
rhyme or reason to most of what he does
something cool oh God in this sense he's
the ultimate virtual martial artist it's
as if he followed the immortal advice of
Bruce Lee be formless shapeless like
water or you know like some other liquid
substance
now most of the time mangos brazenness
works in his favor it allows him to pull
off a ridiculous [ __ ] that no one
expects
well we've seen Plouffe make some
comebacks already oh no tries to cover
the high recovery again Mangal what is
this oh no mango with the sick
conversion look at these mix ups other
times things don't pan out so well
mango lucky westballz vs. PB rocky does
sound like it should be good for him for
SoCal right that's the weight over the
years
mangoes malleability has inspired both
him and his horde of admirers to try to
me Mele encapsulate all of his exploits
into a single offhand phrase oh I like
the mango so what exactly is the mango
well for starters it can signify an
in-game act whether it's something
insanely cool this could be mangoes last
stock of the tournament
oh it's a shine or a downright
humiliating missplay what's that so
anyway here we go can I go like mango
could do something beautiful to your
point of like a really nice edge card
that we'd only know that he would even
think of that kind of scenario and
execute it and say oh that's the mango
like that was so amazing to him double
lasering and being so stubborn to do
something and then dying at 0% for
something it's also the mango and that's
like just the whole spectrum of who he
is but the mango isn't a concept that's
just confined to pixels and polygons if
the man makes one of his signature loser
bracket runs about two is the mango will
this be the last game of the big house
oh well we gonna get five at the
recovery for they're so smart boom beach
already signed him
he up there's mango beats view - king
mango takes the out of beauty Kings arms
and when he takes an L to gravity yeah
that's the mango is a fire alarm went
off last night and mango went up to the
acted or how do you call it like the
opposite of basements yeah yeah yeah and
then yeah basically fell through oh yeah
he fell through there like an honest
stream he tends to be very earnest and
open so you don't just see like one
dimension of mango you see multiple
dimensions like his good his bad his
nice is ugly so like the fact that it's
evolved into being something that could
be anything or categorizes anything is I
think also another mango s kind of
descriptor and while Mele scholars
continue to debate the meaning of the
so-called true mango the consensus is
that well there isn't one and that's the
whole point the mango is literally
anything that mango claims is his
whether or not he actually started it
copyrighted it originated it or
publicize it it whatever mango says is
the mango just becomes the mango see
mango has been around forever
and unlike most of his fellow deities he
isn't known for having perfected a
single character or play style whether
it's puff falcon fox mario or falco he's
pretty much always been the best in the
world that any character he touches that
used to be the mango memes aside
whichever of his myriad of nicknames you
know him by the kid the go-to the Buster
or scorpion master 94 there's simply no
denying the fact that mango is a bona
fide visionary in SoCal and general west
coast everybody wanted to be like mango
and likes his play style his aggression
like I think a lot of the Flair of melee
you know has been influenced by the
mango and how they want to play
everybody goes like I want to be like
Kobe I want to be like Michael and when
you watch a mango video when he's
playing on point you
just want to go pick up Neely and say
like I want to play fox I want to play
falco and I want to play what mangos
playing at the end of the day it doesn't
matter what the dude does to his legion
of adoring fans
it's the mango as far as all of these
stalwarts smelly smashers are concerned
this sloppy squeaky voice Jesus can do
no wrong even when he does and it sort
of makes sense in a world where eSports
is becoming increasingly straight-laced
mango remains as raw and unhinged as
ever and while that's definitely not
even close to always being a good thing
there's no question that mango is for
better or for worse a flawed Rockstar so
I think a lot of people come into melee
they're the type of personalities that
melee brings are this like rebellious
like unstructured type of people to
begin with and like I think mango and
body is like that unstructured I don't
really care about money like I'm gonna
do what I want to do it's like watching
a great artist like you always see
something unexpected and in it when it
works it's like wow like you just like
flabbergasted me it's like he's thinking
on another dimension they're like no one
else is like thinking whether you think
he's a misunderstood genius or a raving
lunatic there's no doubt that mango has
played a vital role in shaping both
smashes culture and competition and on
top of laying the groundwork for what
makes Mele such a complex and skill
intensive game
he's also enamoured entertained and Lord
knows inspired
the difference being that these guys
aren't interested in money and power
no they're obsessed with mastering a
nearly twenty year old game we have to
say party game it's gonna piss people
off so much we have to say party game
yeah yeah oh a little aroused right now
miles oh [ __ ]